Well,
I think the distribution of information
has changed so radically over the last
couple hundred years and particularly
over the last 20 that you're seeing these
trends now where more people are
inclined to abandon a lot of the,
even if you remain religious or remain,
you keep a a thought or a belief in a
higher power p people are more inclined to
entertain these concepts of science and
to take in the understanding of what has
been observed and documented and written
about amongst scholars and academics.
And there's more,
there's more people accepting that.
Have you looked at the number of agnostic
people now as opposed to 2030 years
ago? It's, it's, it's
rising, it's changing.
And I think there's also because of you
and because of Neil degrasse Tyson and
you know,
Sean Carroll and all these other people
that are public intellectuals that are
discussing this kind of stuff,
people like myself have a far greater
understanding of this then I think people
did 30 40 years ago. Yeah. And
that trend is continuing, I think,
in a very good direction. Yeah.
I mean I don't, you know, well,
well we should say is that science,
we don't know all the emphasis so we
don't know where the laws of nature came
from.
We don't know why the universe began in
the way that it did if avian indeed had
a beginning. So I didn't know why the
Big Bang was very, very highly oded,
which is ultimately a show on Carol.
Actually you mentioned him often
points out you need right that the,
the whole difference, the only difference
between the past and the future,
the so called Arrow of time is that in
the past the universe was really old at
and it's getting more disordered
and that's that, that,
that necessary state of, of, of
older, at the start of the universe,
which is really the reason that we exist.
That's the reason cause the
universe began in a particular form.
We don't know why that was. So we, we,
we will probably find out at some point
and there'll be something to do with the
laws of nature. But, so I, I'm
always careful. I don't want to,
as science can sometimes sound arrogant,
right?
It can sometimes sound like it's the,
it's the discipline of saying to people
where you're not, right? Yes. Yeah.
And it's not the discipline of saying
you are not right it saying this is what
we found out.
Yeah.
So I like to say that it provides a
framework within which if you want to
philosophize all you want to
do theology or you want to,
you want to ask these deep
questions about why we're here.
You have to operate within that framework
because it's just an observational
framework. So everything we've
said is stuff we've discovered.
It's not stuff that someone made
up, right? We, we, we, you know,
we understand nuclear physics, we can
build nuclear reactors, for example.
So we understand the physics of styles.
So we understand that the styles built
the carbon and oxygen and we know how
they did it. And we can see,
because as I said before, we can,
if you look far out into the universe,
you're looking way back in time.
And as you look back in time,
you see less carbon and less oxygen.
So we have a direct observation that in
the earliest universe there wasn't any
cause we can see it the now we see that
there is some and we know how it was
made.
So I think it's so it's important to um,
be humble when you're talking about
science and you're not saying this is the
way that it is. I mean, you own
it sense, but you know, it's not,
it's not able to answer ultimate questions
at the moment is not able to answer
even whether the universe had a beginning
or not. We don't even know that.
And I gave it salt to,
um,
I was asked to give a talk to some bishops
in the UK about cosmology and I said,
yeah, that'd be great fun. And so
I went and gave him this talk and,
and at the end I said,
I've got some questions.
So if the universe is eternal and it might
be, it might not have had a beginning.
If it's eternal, what place is there
for a creator? You know, that's,
that's a good question, right?
They didn't, they didn't
have an answer cost, right.
And Eternal Creator. But
yet, but I think that these,
it might be eternal and
we might discover that.
So we don't really know at the moment,
but we might.
So I think my point is
that these other human uh,
designed to be very natural to religions
and natural thing, right? People you say,
oh, across the world in
all different cultures,
but I think that in the 21st century,
it,
religion needs to operate within
that framework. If it's going,
if it's going to operate,
there are still great mysteries and it
is appropriate to think about what it
means to be human and are giving you
my view of what it means. But, but he,
I don't think the problem comes when you,
when your,
your theology or your philosophy
forces you to deny some facts,
some measurement. Now these things
are measurements. We were not saying,
it's not my opinion. The Universe is
13.8 billion years old. We measured it.
It's like having an opinion between
the distance from La to New York.
Then you can't have an opinion on that.
You know what it is. And it's the same,
you know,
slightly know that the things you notice
is the people say the earth's flat or
whatever that is. So it isn't,
we've measured it, so it's
just stop it, you know? So,
but that doesn't mean you can't be
spiritual and you can't be really just,
I would saying it doesn't mean you can't
believe in God or gods are a day that's
not ruled out.